Do y'all see this? That's your king
right here.
>> Yeah, it is. It is. Right.
>> This is your king. Okay. Can I have it?
>> It's been a stir fest.
>> Okay. All right.
>> That's all it's been. You want some?
>> Look, he's he's still Look, you are
really panicking.
>> Hold on, man. He don't want no JW soup,
y'all.
>> Man, I'm out of here, man. You smoke?
I'm gone.
>> Oh, shoot.
>> All right. I wanted to tackle um that uh
Micah I mean Malachi 3:1 you was talking
to my brother about. I'm not sure
exactly why he couldn't answer that for
you. It's very easy. Uh you want to
touch bases on that?
>> Sure.
>> So uh you did mention the temple that
Jesus had well the temple that he was
going to the uh this one was going to uh
you identified it to be John the
messenger. Uh but you failed to you
failed to to didn't talk you didn't talk
about who was the um the messenger of
the covenant. I'm kind of interested of
why didn't you touch bases of that? Who
is that person?
>> Well, we just didn't get there yet. But
yeah, the me yeah, the messenger of the
covenant is the is Jehovah is the Lord
who's coming to his temple.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. So, wait. Um, so
we know you already touched bases on
Malachi of he's preparing the way. Okay.
Uh, we know that was John. We know John
was paving the way for the one that
would come.
>> We know that was Jesus that came. Mhm.
>> Now we also know that the messenger of
the covenant that he brought, Jesus
himself brought was a covenant of the of
the new arrangement and we identify that
to be the new covenant, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So if that is the case,
>> Mhm.
>> the person that is called the messenger
is the same one when the when the uh
Pharisees asked John is he Elijah, he
said no. And then they asked him again,
"Are you the prophet?" Who was who was
they referring to when he said when John
said no to
>> Deuteronomy 18?
>> Who? Okay. So, who were they referring
to? I'm asking the specific question.
When they asked the question, are you
Elijah?
>> They he said no.
>> And he asked him and he asked him the
next question. Are you the prophet? And
he also said no. So, we identify him as
being the one that was preparing the
way.
>> Yeah.
>> For Jesus.
>> Yeah. So, was Jesus the one that they
were talking about as being the prophet?
>> Yes. But they didn't know that at the
time.
>> They didn't know that. But they but they
did know Deuteronomy 18:18 though, which
you just identified.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, if you and I agree that they
identified Deuteronomy 18:18 as Jesus,
the one that's being the prophet, also
called the one that was called being the
way. He would be the way of the new
covenant, which means that he would be
the messenger of the covenant. Now,
Getting back to your question, I agree.
>> Getting back to your question, you asked
whose temple did he come to. Was it his
own temple? You said it was Jehovah. And
you kind of beat my brother in the
corner. So, I'm going to ask you a
question then. And can you turn to uh
>> So, so you Hebrews.
>> So, you got you got that energy of do it
to me then, huh?
>> No, no, no, no, no. I I was in the
comments. I just I just did I was hoping
my brother saw it, but he didn't he
didn't see my comments. Okay. I was
trying to share with him to show you
something. Well, I ask you a question.
Could we go to Hebrews uh uh 3? Sure.
>> Verse 6. I want you to tell me whose uh
whose temple is this?
>> Okay,
>> please. All right. Now, we we identify
who the messenger was. We identify who
the prophet was. We we identify who was
the one the messenger of the covenant
and which we all identify as the new
covenant. So, who is this way that's
paving the way for Jehovah?
>> Do you think Wait, hold on. Cuz I'm I'm
a little confused.
>> Okay.
>> So, do you think that I disagree that
Jesus is the messenger of the covenant?
>> Oh, no. I know you don't, but you
identify Jesus as being Jehovah. I know
that too,
>> right? Based based on what Malachi 3 is
saying because the messenger of the
covenant is is Jehovah is the Lord.
>> I got I get you. And mind you, Isaiah,
not only Isaiah, but Elijah both was
were doing the same process in which uh
John had to do was pave the way for true
worship. Now, we're going to find out
how this way of true worship identifies
Jehovah coming to his temple by means of
Christ Jesus paving the way for true
worship. So, we're going to we're going
to knock that down real quick. So, so
just wait. So, you're saying that Isaiah
and Elijah prepared the way for for
Jehovah?
>> No, they paved the road for true worship
as it was identified as something that
happened in the past in which true
worship had to be done. Obviously,
wasn't done, but Jesus would will pave
the true way of true worship, but it
would be by means of repentance first
for Israel through John.
>> So, wait, cuz you're you're moving a
little too fast, man. You got to slow
down for me.
>> Oh, I thought you knew this already.
>> No, no. Yeah, I'm I'm learning, man. I'm
going to start
>> Oh. Oh, I I see. Okay. You got You got
900 people in here, brother. You can't
be learning nothing.
>> Oh, 900 people in here, man. There's 900
900 people on TikTok. Bro, there's 4,100
people on YouTube watching. So, we got
>> There you go. There you go. Okay. So, we
going to knock this down, brother. I'm
I'm a student. Okay. So, we agree that
John the Baptist is preparing the way
for Jehovah. Correct.
>> Mhm. Yes, sir.
>> Okay. So, he's preparing the way for
Jehovah
>> and Jehovah, the Lord, is going to come
to his own temple. Correct. Jehovah is
coming to his temple. Yes.
>> Okay. And it even and it identifies
Jehovah the Lord coming to his temple as
it says it even No, it doesn't say by
means of.
>> No, no, I get it. I get it. We want to
get to that in a second. We want to get
to that right now.
>> And it says even the messenger of the
covenant in whom he's coming. So Jehovah
is the is the messenger of the covenant
who's coming to his own temple.
>> Right. Right. Okay. So now let's now you
asked a specific question to my brother
about whose temple was it? So, we're
going to tackle that to find out
exactly. And this pretty much is going
to knock everything down. Just one verse
really.
>> Do you do you mind if I read a few
verses ahead?
>> I have no problem. Please go ahead. I'll
start your business. It says,
"Therefore, holy brothers, you who share
in a heavenly calling, consider Jesus
the apostle and high priest of our
confession, who was faithful to him who
appointed him, just as Moses also was
faithful in all God's house. For Jesus
has been counted worthy of more glory
than Moses, as much more glory as the
builder of a house has more honor than
the house itself. For every house is
built by someone, but the builder of all
things is God. Now, Moses was faithful
in all God's house as a servant to
testify to the things that were to be
spoken later. But Christ is faithful
over God's house as a son and we are his
house if indeed we hold fast our
confidence and our boasting in our hope.
Okay. So the topic is um obviously uh
God's house we're talking about here.
We're talking about faithfulness in
God's house and the example everyone has
showed starting with Moses. Jesus would
be the uh corresponding uh uh person
that would uh oversee Moses. But you
see, they're identified as being ones
that were faithful in the same house,
which we'll identify to be the temple.
Now if we depict this temple to not be
that same house that Jesus worshiped in
in the past with the uh the ones in the
past and the same house even before
Jesus came to earth if this is the same
temple that we're talking about that he
was going to was that Jesus temple or or
God's temple according to Hebrews 3 1 1
through uh six in which you just read
beautifully by the way.
>> Thank you. So, I'm a little confused on
your question, brother. The setup was a
little confusing to me.
>> Well, I thought that was very very Well,
we're talking about the same temple.
What are you Well, well, this this
mentioned Let me help you out a little
bit more just really quick. Go ahead.
>> In Hebrews 3, it mentioned two different
houses, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Yes. Yes, sir.
>> Okay. So, one is talking about the
temple and then two is talking about us.
The body us. Exactly right. Yeah, you're
right. You're exactly right.
>> Okay. So, in Malachi, you're because
you're trying to bring this like and
connect us to Malachi. In Malachi when
it says that the Lord whom you seek will
suddenly come to his temple. What is it
talking? What temple is it talking
about?
>> We're talking about the literal temple.
>> Okay. So I
>> the literal temple.
>> So how is this connected?
>> So okay now you painted my brother in a
corner and asked him the question who
whose temple was that?
>> Yeah.
>> Now we know by means of Jesus situation
he was under law. The temple in which
Jesus would be in according to law would
be God's temple or God's house. Now the
body we're talking about that you
identify to be two different temples,
you're right. That would be later on.
This is the whole point of John uh
chapter 4 uh 23 to uh 22- 24. That's the
point of it. Now specifically talking
about the physical temple, Jesus was
under law to be in that temple just like
the rest of the Israelites. So if Jesus
came to that same temple that you're
claiming that was Jehovah himself, are
you saying that Jesus as Jehovah was
coming to his own temple?
>> Yes, that's what it says.
>> That's what it that's what it says. It
says the Lord whom you seek will come to
his own temple.
>> Okay. So rightes just real quick is is
that correct that according to Malachi
3, Jehovah is going to come to his own
temple. Right.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So that's what the Bible says.
>> Okay. So that's what the Bible says. But
your interpretation tells you that that
was Jehovah and which came to his own
temple. Now
>> you just you just agree. No, brother.
Cuz when you say interpretation, that's
that's when we get kind of
>> No, I get it, bro. I get it. I get it.
But you you guys have you you guys have
a way that you interpret things to
assume that it is the Jehovah himself in
which cannot be in any house that's
built by man's hands.
>> Okay. So, let let's let's pause here.
Okay.
>> Okay. Can we agree that Malachi 3:1
like literally says Jehovah's coming to
his own temple?
>> Yes.
>> All right. So, it's not my
interpretation. Not twisting it. That's
what the verse actually says. Okay.
>> Yes.
>> So, now now you're saying that Jehovah
can't dwell in a temple built with
hands.
>> Mhm.
>> Where does it where does the Bible say
that?
>> So,
>> you're thinking of First Kings 8, by the
way.
>> Yes. That's where we're going. Now, now
it's now it's we don't have to go there
because you already know it. point of
the we do that's fine
>> because the con first Kings 8 disproves
what you just said that God cannot dwell
in a building made with hands because in
first Kings 8 when you read prior to
Solomon's prayer when he says something
like that where he says uh heaven and
earth can't contain you so will you even
will you actually live in this house
when heaven and earth can't contain you
but that's after God
comes down and dwells in the temple his
glory fills the temple
So, so I if you're that smart to
understand that, you will have to be as
smart as the next person that assumes
the same thing to to know the fact that
anyone that comes in represent in
representation of God will be the the
glory that God sends on his behalf.
>> No, you don't need you don't even need
to hear the word agency to understand
that God's mist is the glory that he he
resides in.
>> Okay, brother, do me this favor. Can you
can you show me where it said that
somebody other than Jehovah dwelt in the
temple in in Jerusalem?
>> What do you What do you mean? You're not
going to find that. That's that's
Jehovah.
>> So So why in the world are you bringing
up representatives when it when there's
no representative in in in in question?
It's Jehovah himself dwelling in the
temple.
>> Okay. So let me ask you this. Let let me
see if you want to be honest then. I'm
trying. Was Jehovah in the Was Jehovah
in the clouds?
>> Yes.
>> Was Jehovah in the fire?
>> Was Jehovah in the um in the in the the
the fire?
>> Yes. I just said yes.
>> Okay. Was he Well, I'm sorry. I'm not
meant to say fire, but but um the the
wind. So, you know where I'm going with
this, right? So, when he talked to
Elijah and he says, "I was not talking
about that one."
>> Well, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Hold
on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
>> I thought you were talking about
different
>> inst No, no, no, no. You No, no, no. You
know where I'm going. Like, like you're
smart enough.
>> No, brother. was because he was in the
fire when he when he appeared to Moses.
>> So when he was he was in the cloud he
was in the cloud when he saved uh uh
when he saved Egypt I mean uh Israel
from the land of Egypt. So I thought
that I thought you were talking about
these different instances like literally
literally numbers that says that that
Yahweh was in the cloud and he traveled
with Israel as they traveled the nations
bro. So
>> I I I know you're smart enough to
understand. I know you're smart enough
to appreciate the compliment. you you
you know plenty of of information, but I
want to see if you're going to actually
be honest, though. And when he talked to
Elijah,
>> have I been dishonest at all this year?
>> No, I I don't I don't I think you're
being dishonest with your with your uh
platform. Of course.
>> What do you mean what I lie about?
>> Bro, logic. I like you. I'm I'm not
going to lie. I do listen to you. I do
listen to you. I'm not going to lie. But
I want to make sure that if you're
talking to me, I'm going to be as honest
as as I can. And I hope you are too.
What I'm saying, what I'm saying is when
he speaks to individuals like he did
Elijah when the cl when the fire and all
the earthquake and everything else going
and he says, "I was not in it."
>> Mhm.
>> But yet we're saying that he was in the
fire. He was in the cloud.
>> No. No. No. No. No. So, can I can I stop
you, please?
>> I have no problem. You can stop anytime
you want. Show your platform. Listen, I
just said that when you were asking me
these questions, I was not thinking of
the situation spec the specific
situation with Elijah. I thought that
you were talking about in general
throughout the Old Testament where God
is in the fire in Exodus 3, where God is
in the cloud in Exodus where he's when
he's saving the people out of the land
of of Israel and when he's in the cloud
traveling with Israel in the book of
Numbers and in the book of Deuteronomy.
So that's what I thought you were
talking about in the different
instances. But of course with the
specific situation with Elijah when the
fire comes, the uh thunder comes, the
wind comes that God was not in that but
it was the voice, right? So yeah, but
you have the other instances. Do you
agree that the other instances God is in
the fire with Moses? God is in the
pillar of the cloud with uh with the
Israelites that you agree with that
>> point the point yeah listen I'm I'm
agreeing with you only if you're going
to be honest with me on my next point
when I go to seven uh Acts 7:38 this is
where I was going with you okay I want
to see if you want to be honest Acts
7:38 and we're talking about the same
incidences 38 it says this is the one
who came to be among the congregation of
the wilderness with the angel who spoke
to him.
>> Was Jehovah that angel?
>> Yes. Jehovah says he was that angel.
>> Jehovah was that ang. So when I go back
to Exodus 23 20-23, Jehovah God says, "I
am sending an angel."
>> Mhm.
>> And this one, I'm going to be specific
cuz mind you, I'm just I'm just going
with what you're saying. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> All right. I'm going there. I am
definitely going to go there. I like you
though, bro. I I do really do like you.
I like you, too.
>> I'm going go to Exodus 23. This is the
same incident. Let's find out if you're
going to be if you're going to keep
being honest.
>> No, that's not the same incident. I am
listen to this. I am sending an angel uh
ahead of you.
>> You said Acts 7:38.
>> No, no, listen. This is this is the same
angel.
>> I agree. I agree it's the same angel.
But in Acts 7:38 is talking about the
burning bush.
>> No, no, logic. This is all we platform.
Yeah, I know it's my platform. So, you
agree that in Acts 7, Steven is
referencing the burning bush incident
with Moses.
>> Listen, this is this the whole point of
it, bro, is this is the same angel. I'm
talking about whoever come I agree it's
the same angel.
>> So so okay now we we both agree. So this
same angel this one here in Exodus 23
20- 20 23 it says I am sending an angel
ahead of you.
>> Yeah.
>> Who is who is I?
>> That's the father.
>> That's the father. I am sending an
angel. Now is the father the angel?
>> No.
>> Wait a minute. Wait wait wait wait. Hold
on. So we just went through whole
Malachi.
>> Wait. Can you can you finish reading the
verse?
>> No, no. I I have no I am, but I want to
make sure we're clear because you're
saying that the same one is this same
one that's called the angel. You say
that the angel the angel of God was
Jehovah.
>> Yes. Okay.
>> So, so, so we see so we're going to see
we see that there's a distinction
between the father and the angel. Yet,
the angel is still identified as Jehovah
just like the father is. So, we're
seeing that Jehovah is multiple persons,
not just the father.
>> Oh, yeah. Okay. Yes. This is what I like
about I I can tell you the the U
trinitarians is the best dancers cuz
they can swing and and go to a whole
another level.
>> Do you mind finishing the verse?
>> I love how y'all dance. I'll tell you
what, y'all got the best Tik Tok dance.
>> I appreciate it. Can you finish the
verse?
>> Jehovah Witnesses can bring them out to
bring it out from y'all. So listen,
let's see. Let's watch this dance for
finish the verse. Let's see how good you
dance.
>> Hey, watch this dance y'all. It says, "I
am sending the father is sending an
angel who he said is God." Who was who
was Jehovah? ahead of you to guard you
on the way and to bring you into the
place that I have prepared.
>> Pay attention to him. Is that the father
or the angel?
>> The angel.
>> Okay. And obey his voice. Whose voice?
>> Woo. The angels. That's tough.
>> Do not Okay. Do not rebel against him.
The angel, right?
>> Why?
>> For he will not pardon your transgress.
>> What?
>> Oh,
>> he can forgive. He can forgive sins.
Tough.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Wait. He But but why? Why can't he Why
can't he Why can't he forgive sins? Why?
I have no problem with that. Same when I
was in Fin. The same when I was in
Isaiah.
>> Okay. Thank you. Finish.
>> The same when I was in Isaiah. I'm okay
with that,
>> brother. Finish it.
>> I am I I am truly okay with that,
brother.
>> Brother, finish it. Okay. Finish it.
You're my dad's partner right now. Okay.
>> So, finish it.
>> Logic. You my boy, man. It say It says
It says um It says uh because my name is
in you.
So you mean to tell me that the a that
the father identifies the angel as
Jehovah?
>> Guess what Jesus' name mean? Jehovah
salvation.
>> OH.
SO SO LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT NOW.
WATCH THIS. So the angel here is
identified as Jehovah as bearing the
same. Wait, hold on a second cuz watch
this. Go ahead, baby. Go ahead.
>> We just slow cooker. It's just getting
started.
>> It's Yes. I love it. Go.
>> Good. So the angel is identified as
Jehovah
>> bearing the name of Jehovah. The name of
Jehovah is in him.
>> Yes.
>> Right. Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> In the angel. Now watch this.
>> Here's here's the kicker.
>> All right. Do me this favor.
>> Go ahead and go to Nehemiah chapter 9
verse six.
>> Okay. When Okay. I wasn't done, but I'm
going to go to your verse, but I'm
coming right behind you. Okay. All
right. Nehemiah chapter 9. Okay. Yes,
sir. I got you, bro. I was supposed to
be sleeping. I'm listening to you, man.
I don't mess around and got in trouble
by my wife, bro.
>> Tell her to give you a few more minutes,
man. We partying over here.
>> I hear you, bro.
>> Yeah. Shout out to the wife. Shout out.
>> Yeah, I hear that, babe. He say she
said, "All right. Where you at,
brother?"
>> Okay.
>> Uh Nehemiah chapter 9 verse 6.
>> Okay. It says, "You alone are Jehovah.
You made the heavens." Yes. the heavens
of the heavens and all their armies, the
earth and all that is in on it, the seas
and all that is in them. And you
preserve all of them alive, and the
armies of the heavens are bowing down to
you.
>> So only one bears the name of Jehovah,
correct? Alone.
>> Yes. Mhm.
>> But you just showed me that the father
and the angel of the father, the angel
of Jehovah
>> also are have bear the name Jehovah.
>> Mhm.
>> According to this, it says
>> that you are Jehovah alone.
>> Yes.
>> So either we have a contradiction where
there's somebody else who's not Jehovah,
who's not the creator of the heavens and
the earth, who's identified as Jehovah,
the angel of the Lord, who's a a spirit
creature.
>> And there's a contradiction here. or
Jehovah is multi-personal. He's the
father and he's the angel of the Lord
Jesus Christ and he's the Holy Spirit.
>> Wow. So that's beautiful, bro. So So I'm
so glad you did that because this
actually you you actually ran to my
point and I have never seen nobody do it
that good. You I'm telling you, not only
you a dancer, but you're a track star,
bro. So I'm going to show you something,
bro, because this is interesting for a
full song. Isaiah 43. I love this verse
here. 437 uh down. And I know you know
>> Are you not gonna deal with what I just
brought up?
>> No, I'm about to do it right now. I'm
gonna do it right now.
>> Okay. So, you're about to explain how
the angel do it right now. So, so you're
about to explain how the angel is
identified as Jehovah
>> while there's no one else who is
identified as Jehovah according to
>> you want me to do it that way. I'm going
to I'm going to do it the way
>> Well, yeah. How? Look, however, my
brother, I'm I'm let I'm letting you
have it. I'm saying how however you deal
with it. Yeah. Make make sure you're
dealing with the point I just raised.
>> Yeah. Oh, bro. I got you, bro. I'm
telling you, you're not you're my man. I
like you, my man. L Come on, baby.
>> So, let's see. Let's see something right
here. And this is uh uh Isaiah 43.
>> This is a beautiful scripture.
>> Mhm.
>> It says, "Everyone who is called by my
name." Wait a minute. Come on. Nehemiah,
you literally just said that he alone
has that name. But it says everyone who
is called by my name. But it goes on. It
says in whom I what? Created for my own
glory. Exodus 23 20-23.
My name is in him. Created for my own
glory. Created key word whom I have
formed and made. Isn't that partly a
part of the earth creation?
bring out a people who are blind through
uh uh though they have eyes and who are
uh deaf though have ears. Let all the
nations assemble in one place and let
the peoples be gathered together. Who
among them can tell this? Or can they
cause us to hear the first things? Let
them present their witnesses to prove
themselves right. I see you witnesses
down there, baby. It says, "You are my
witnesses, declared Jehovah." Yes, my
servants whom I chosen.
>> Nice.
>> So that you may know and have faith in
me and understand that I am the same
one, Nehemiah.
The same one, Nehemiah.
Before me, no God was formed, and after
me there will be none. So, anyone that's
created for the glory of God is called
by Jehovah's name.
>> What does that mean?
>> What does that mean? I'll take it to
another scripture and let you do it
yourself. You tell me when I go to Acts
15.
>> No, if you if you could just simply tell
me what does it mean to be called by
>> That's one thing about Jehovah
Witnesses. That's one thing about
Jehovah Witnesses. We don't liure. So,
well, you did you just gave me a lot of
lip. You just gave me a lot of lip. I
>> gave you scripture, bro. I gave you
scripture. So, this this is what I'm
asking cuz you didn't you didn't address
what I asked.
>> Oh, Mike, come on. Chat,
>> brother, brother Mikey, you got to you
got to let me talk. I just let you talk,
right?
>> All right.
>> Come on.
>> So So, so Mikey, Mikey, listen.
>> Go ahead, baby.
>> I just asked you about uh Jehovah, the
creator, being the only one who is
identified as Jehovah. Mhm.
>> Now, when you said then you read a
scripture and it says that all who are
called by my name
>> Mhm.
>> are these people identified as Jehovah?
>> They're called Yeah, they're identified
by Jehovah. Yes.
>> So,
>> I'm I'm going show you another script.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Go
ahead.
>> So, just to be clear, you're saying that
Israel is identified as Jehovah.
>> They're called Jehovah.
>> Anyone that represents Jehovah is called
by his name. No, no, not Israel. No, no,
no. Not Israel now. No. No. Now. Not
Israel now.
>> So this is this is talking about is who
is he? This is talking about Israel.
Correct.
>> Now this is No. No. No. This is now.
>> This is future.
>> Who is who is Yahweh? Who is Yahweh
speaking to?
>> This is future. This is this is this is
something that's going to I'm I'm going
to show you. This is this is the future
right here. I'm I'm going to tell you
right now. Acts 15. Let's go there. This
is what Isaiah was talking about right
here.
>> I got you. But
>> this is the future. Isaiah 15.
>> And Mikey, hold on a second, please.
Thank you.
It says, "But now thus says Yahweh, he
who created you, oh Jacob, he who formed
you, oh Israel." Who's he speaking to?
>> Of course you you know you're speaking
about the Israel. Of course. No, no
doubt.
>> All right. So you just said you just
wait hold on hold on.
>> So he's speaking hold. So he's speaking
to Israel, correct?
>> In the immediate context.
>> Okay, that's fine.
>> Okay, cool. So in speaking to Israel,
okay,
>> and he talks about how Israel is called
by his name because he chose him
obviously.
>> My question is, is Israel identified as
Jehovah?
>> I gave you the answer. No.
>> So being called by Jehovah's name
>> Mhm.
>> is not meaning that they're identified
as Jehovah or they are bear the name
Jehovah. It means that Jehovah chose
them. He picked them out. Correct.
>> Right. Right. Yes, sir. So this has
nothing to do
>> with my argument.
>> Okay?
>> Jehovah Jehovah picking someone, calling
people in his name,
>> picking people has nothing to do with
the angel of the Lord bearing the name
of Jehovah, having the name of Jehovah
in him
when no one can be identified as
Jehovah. Nehemiah 9:6.
>> So I need you. You said you was going to
address my argument. Coming here didn't
address my argument. And I'm still am,
brother. If you if you if you hold
tight, I'm going to help you to see how
you just debunked the fact that you are
even allowed to be considered a follower
of Christ or even Christian if you
believe it was still talking about
Israel.
>> I agree. Look, I know. Do can we agree
that there can be immediate context and
also fulfillment?
>> Future fulfillment.
>> Of course. Yes. Of course.
>> Okay. So So none none of this is
negating what I'm saying. What I'm
asking you to do specifically is I'm
asking you to deal with my argument that
no one can be identified as Jehovah. Yet
the angel of the Lord is identified as
Jehovah. How do you deal with that?
Because Israel is not identified as
Jehovah.
>> The kingdom all the the the anointed
class is not identified as Jehovah.
>> Nobody else is identified as Jehovah.
>> Okay. So going back to what I said first
off anyone it was names in the Bible I'm
sorry names in the Hebrew times that
identified as being Jehovah right so the
the uh Jehoshaphat all those names what
does that represent
>> these are these are people's names
>> right what what does it mean in them
>> but what does it what does it mean
though
>> it doesn't mean that they're Jehovah
they're not called Jehovah
>> but was Jehovah's name in them though
>> no it's not in them
>> wait Wait,
>> show me show me where his name represent
Show me where it says that Jehovah's
name is in any of these people.
>> First off, the individual's names
>> Mhm.
>> that we're speaking of.
>> Yeah.
>> Those individuals had Jehovah's name and
it meant something in there, right?
>> What does that have to do with anything?
What is
>> Because you're saying that
you're saying Jehovah's name itself.
You're saying Jehovah's name itself. No
one could have that name but him. But
people's names are are are given based
on his name.
>> No worries. Are they are they called
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on a second. Is
their name Jehovah?
>> No, that's not the point, bro.
>> So, you're missing my point.
>> Brother, let me actually still man you.
I'm I'm a steel man you. Meaning, I'm
going to represent you correct. Well, I
got an audience audience, right? So, I'm
going to represent your point correctly.
You're saying that people bear within
their names in the Hebrew scriptures
within their names their name uh Jehovah
is part of their name.
>> Do you disagree with that first?
>> I don't I do not disagree.
>> Okay.
>> So Jehovah being part of their name or a
piece of Jehovah's name being part of
their name,
>> it makes up like Jehoshaphat or Elijah,
right? Yada yada yada.
>> Yes.
>> But they themselves their actual name
Elijah Jehoshaphat or whatever their
name is not Jehovah.
Right?
>> So saying having a name saying for
example Jehovah provides or Jehovah is
my healer that's not their their name is
not Jehovah but their name points to
Jehovah right. So let let me can I can I
show you a scripture and you tell me
something?
>> Would you agree that their name points
to Jehovah?
>> So So one second, bro. I'm going to read
the scripture.
>> I need a yes or no on that.
>> Yes. Okay. Now, now let me let me let me
go here now.
>> So, I need you to deal with my argument.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> The angel of the Lord is identified as
Jehovah
>> when nobody else can be.
>> So, how do you how do you fix that?
>> Okay. The Hebrew scriptures
>> Mhm.
>> Joel 2:32.
>> And everyone who is called
on the name of Jehovah will be saved.
>> Every Wait, say that again. Read it.
Read it again. And everyone who is who
calls on the name of Jehovah. You
misread it the first time. So everyone
who calls on the name of Jehovah will be
saved.
>> Will be saved. Right.
>> Right. According to According to Peter,
who does he apply that to?
>> Of course, we we know who we call we
apply to uh Jesus, right?
>> So according
So I don't have a problem with that.
>> I I'm glad you don't because now cuz now
you about to leave Jehovah's Witnesses.
>> Wait, wait. No, no, no, hold on. Listen.
So if Peter applies this verse
>> to Jesus, all who call on the name of
Jehovah will be saved. Whose name does
does Peter say is the name by which
everyone who calls upon
>> will be saved and no one else's name?
>> I have no problem with that, bro.
>> Whose is it?
>> Listen, Jesus name. I have a problem
with that.
>> You got to say his name, baby, bro.
>> So who does that make Jesus?
>> Listen, I did that for a reason.
>> I have no problem with that.
>> Who does that make Jesus?
>> The fact of the matter. Okay. When Jesus
says, "Up until now, YOU HAVE NOT CALLED
on me at all." Up until now, what does
that mean?
>> What?
>> Up I'll show you right now.
>> In John 14, Hold on. I wasn't done.
>> I I brother respect, bro. With all due
respect,
I do not care about all of these other
segways and red herrings because even
this right here that I'm entertaining is
a segue against away from what I
originally asked you about the angel of
the Lord being identified as Jehovah.
But you brought me something that's also
is just as juicy. I couldn't hold help
myself.
>> I don't have a problem with that, bro.
I'm agreeing with you.
>> I know. So, you agree that it's at the
name of Jesus wholeheartedly. So okay.
So then
>> so you this is where the problem is
either Jesus is Jehovah by whose name
everyone is to be saved or it's not just
at Jehovah's name that everyone is to be
saved but there's a creature an agent
who's not Jehovah by whose name you are
to be saved.
>> How do you reconcile that as as a
Jehovah?
>> You're not you're not breaking the bank
with that with your with your statement.
THE THE MONEY SPILLING OUT. WHAT YOU
>> THAT'S NOT LISTEN, you and I both agree
that there's no way of salvation by but
but by means of Jesus Christ can come
through the father except through Jesus.
>> Whose name? I have no problem with that.
>> Whose name?
>> Except through Jesus Christ. I have no
problem with that.
>> So, but who according to Joel?
>> Who? Wait, hold on. According to Joel,
whose name is everyone to call on in
order to be saved? According
to Joel, I just read Jehovah's name.
>> So, can you be saved by anybody else's
name other than Jehovah? Yes or no?
>> Yes, you can be saved.
What do you mean, bro? Just let me get
the stage. Can I get the stage? You keep
talking. I'm giving you I'll let you
talk the whole entire time. Let me get
the stage now. All right. Now, how do we
get to Jehovah?
Why is Jesus called the way? You're not
saying nothing THAT'S BREAKING THE BANK.
HOW DO WE GET TO JEHOVAH? Why is he
called the way?
>> You you you think that Jesus isn't the
destination either?
>> What? No, no, NO. YOU'RE SAYING THE
FINAL DESTINATION, BUT Jesus is called
the way. What is he the way to
>> to the father? And and how do you how do
you how do you get to the sun?
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. You
at the stage.
>> How do you How do you get to the sun?
>> Bro, you Bro, bro,
>> I can't let you escape. How do you get
to the sun?
>> 2 Chronicles 16:9. That's how
John 6:44. That's how John Jesus says,
"No one can come to me unless the father
draws them."
>> So, so who's the way to draw them?
>> Exactly. So, hold on. So, the way to the
father is the son
>> yourself in a corner.
>> Hold on. The way to just have Mikey,
chill. I'm going to give it to you. I
promise.
>> No, you ain't going to give it to me. I
see you now. I promise. I promise.
>> You're panicking now.
>> Oh, okay. You could you can say it.
>> You are panicking. The way to the father
is the son and the way to the son is the
father. You ain't breaking the bank with
this. You keep trapping yourself, bro.
>> Beautiful. Beautiful. That's why John
3:17
says that, right? Do we agree?
>> Yep.
>> Do we agree that John 17:3 says exactly
what you and I just said.
>> Another jump.
>> Do you agree?
>> Yeah, I agree. Another jump though.
>> So, hold on. Hold on. So, now we're
getting back to your Nehemiah. We're
getting back to there. We're agreeing
now. You're right. So now you're
Nehemiah. I I asked you to go to Acts 15
for me because I'm answering your
question still. I did not run from your
question.
>> You did. You have you you haven't
touched on the angel of the Lord being
identified as Jehovah. And neither have
you cuz you said that there is a name
other than Jehovah by which you can be
saved.
>> That's what you said, right?
>> Bro, there is no way to get to Jehovah
but by means of Jesus Christ. It was UP
UNTIL THEN THAT COULD HAPPEN. OTHER THAN
THAT, IT WAS JUST JEHOVAH.
>> All right.
>> Other Okay. Ask me this, bro. Ask me
this.
>> Watch this.
>> Ask me this, bro. Ask me this, bro.
>> Hold on. Watch. I'm going to I'm going
to read cuz you said you you only do
scripture, right?
>> Hold on. I'm I'm I'm okay with that. I
want to ask you a question.
>> Let me ask you a question, bro.
>> You ask this question. I'm going to go
through these verses once you ask.
>> I want I want to be I want you to be
sincerely honest, bro.
>> Okay? Please.
If and we're sticking to uh Joel 2:32
for a moment.
>> Mhm.
>> If Adam and Eve
had not sinned,
would Jesus have to come down?
>> Uh I would say I would say if no one
sinned, Jesus wouldn't have to come
down.
>> No, no, no. I'm specifically saying Adam
because he's the father.
>> Yeah, but you're saying you're you're
acting as if Adam was the only one who
was like, you know, capable.
>> No, bro. But Bill, the command was given
to Adam. It says in
if Adam and if Adam had sons and and
they and they committed sin, would Jesus
need to come down and save them?
>> No. No. It's Adam.
>> I disagree.
>> It's Adam. That's the first That's the
whole point of First Corinthians 15.
Bro, are you really going to be that
disingenuous?
>> I I I disagree. But that's another
subject.
>> Wow. So, wait, wait, wait. You got your
panel. YOU TALKING TO A PANEL, BRO.
>> You literally just said that this is
>> Mikey, please.
>> Are you serious?
>> Watch this.
>> Hold on. Back. We're going back to this.
Watch this. This is
>> This is 54.
>> I'm still answering my question.
>> No, you're not. You're not answering
anything. You're changing the subject.
So, watch this. I'm about to go ahead
and give you the verses. You're the only
one, bro.
>> Mikey, respectfully, brother. I don't
want to have to mute you, man. We've
been talking respectfully so far. I'm
about to
>> Oh, now I'm getting muted. I thought we
as friends,
>> so respect me as a friend and relax.
>> All right.
>> You panicking, bro. I ain't never seen
you do this,
>> I guess. Yeah, I'm panicking, but you
you're not letting me read the verse.
Do y'all see this?
>> Yeah, that makes sense a lot.
>> THAT'S YOUR THAT'S YOUR KING RIGHT HERE.
>> YEAH, it is. It is. Watch this. Psalm 54
says, actually, uh, let's go up. We're
going to start.
>> This is your king.
>> Psalm 25:11. For your name's sake, oh
Yahweh. Pardon my guilt, for it is
great. For whose name?
>> Jehovah.
>> So, by whose name are we forgiven, and
our sins are pardoned?
>> Of course, Jehovah. That's that's the
Hebrews. That's that's the 14th.
>> Let's keep going. Let's keep going. Oh
God, save me by your name. I'mma keep
reading. Oh God, save me by your name.
Whose name?
>> That's Jehovah.
>> Okay. And vindicate me by your might.
Let's keep going.
Help us, oh God, of our salvation for
the glory of your name. Deliver us and
atone for our sins for your name's sake.
By whose name's sake? And for whose
name's sake are our sins forgiven and
atoned for?
Who's
>> you already know that's Jehovah? I have
no problem.
>> Okay, awesome. Jehovah. Jehovah.
Jehovah. Oh, we going to see.
>> That's the Hebrew. That was literally
before Jesus came.
>> I I am he who blotss out your
transgressions for my own sake. And I
will not remember your sins. For whose
sake?
>> My own sake.
>> So for Jehovah's name's sake, for
Jehovah's sake, our sins are pardoned,
our guilt is removed, our sin is
forgiven, and our transgressions are
blotted out. Is that correct?
>> Yeah. Right. Okay, let's keep going.
Isaiah 45. Declare and present your
case. Let them take counsel together.
Who told who told this long ago? Who
declared it of old? Was it not I,
Jehovah? And there is no other God
besides me, a righteous God and a
savior. There is none besides me. Turn
to me and be saved all the ends of the
earth. For I am God and there is no
other. Is there another God
>> by which we are saved?
>> No, not at all. Okay, good job. Awesome.
>> Mhm.
>> So now watch my turn.
>> I'm going to show you.
>> Here's Luke 24.
>> Then he said to them, "These are my
words that I spoke to you while I was
still with you that everything written
about me in the law of Moses, the
prophets, and the psalms must be
fulfilled." He opened their minds to
understand the scripture. Watch this.
And thus it is written that the Christ
should suffer and on the third day rise
from the dead and that repentance for
the forgiveness of sins should be
proclaimed in his name
>> to all nations beginning from Jerusalem.
In whose name do we receive atonement?
Do we receive forgiveness? Whose name?
Jehovah's name. Right.
>> Yes.
>> But Jesus said it's his name. Mhm.
>> So, so Jehovah's name is is the name of
Christ?
>> No, not at all.
>> SO, OKAY. SO, so now can I have a mic
now?
>> Yeah. Yeah. You explain explain whose
name explain this.
>> Everything Everything you just did, you
did a great job explaining the Hebrews.
>> And you just contradicted yourself.
>> Everything that you just explained. Now,
I ain't say nothing to you. I was just
agree on everything you said. You asked
me a question, I said yes.
>> And you contradicted yourself.
>> All right. Okay. You got I love the
spoon. So, I want to see if you can cook
this up. It's too much.
>> Everything up until Jesus come. Let's go
to uh John 16. Here's what Jesus is
here. We're not going anywhere else. Oh,
>> this is we I I let you go all around the
world. Do y'all see this all day
>> today? Right now for this, you're going
to deal with this directly.
>> John 16.
>> By whose name, according to Jesus, by
whose name do we receive forgiveness of
sins and repentance? You literally just
read all the Hebrew scriptures that
identify that Jehovah God is the only
one that's doing anything. Thank you,
sir.
>> So, let's do this one last time then.
Bring Jesus to the picture.
>> Hold on. One last time. Well, Jesus is
already in the picture going on.
>> Jesus said, "Thus it is written that the
Christ
>> should suffer and on the third day rise
from the dead, and that repentance for
the forgiveness of sins should be
proclaimed in his name." Whose name?
I'm sorry, my daughter talking to me.
I'm sorry. What' you say?
>> I'll do it again.
>> Okay. Go ahead.
>> Thus it is written that the Christ
should suffer. The Christ
>> should suffer
>> and on the third day rise from the dead.
>> Mhm. Yes.
>> And that repentance for the forgiveness
of sins should be proclaimed in his
name. Whose name?
>> Jesus name.
>> So there you go. So it's in Jesus's name
that all sin is atoned for, repentance
is offered, and the forgiveness of sins
is handed out. But according to the Old
Testament, by whose name was repentance
given? By whose name was repent
repentance available for? F forgiveness
of sins, pardon of guilt, and
transgression.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Got you. All
right.
>> Who's whose name?
>> Oh, that's Jehovah's name back then. And
now it's Jesus name now.
>> SO WHEN DOES JEHOVAH'S NAME BACK THEN?
>> So accord So according to you, it
switched. It changed salvation. The
direction and subject of salvation
changed from Jehovah to a creature
>> of his son. Yes. By means of the son.
That's actual scripture. Welcome to
Welcome to Jehovah's Witness doctrine.
>> Okay, hold on. No,
>> polytheism at
>> No, you're right. You're right.
>> YOU JUST TOLD ME THAT IT'S BY NO OTHER
GOD that we be saved.
>> So So logic, by you keep talking, it
seems like it seemed like now you're
really panicking cuz I got you in a
corner now. This that doesn't that
doesn't work on anybody.
>> So can you please
>> The only the only thing that's been
happening so far, my brother Mikey, is
this right here.
>> Okay. Can I
>> It's been a stir fest.
>> Okay. All right.
>> That's all it's been.
>> Sir, can I get on now?
>> Yeah. Okay. But first,
>> are you ready?
>> But first, I want
>> you ready?
>> Do you want some?
>> Look, he's he's still Look, you are
really panicking.
>> I have never seen you do that before.
>> Hey, do y'all see this panel over 13?
>> I have y'all ever seen him do this?
>> Do you want some?
>> Can I'm going to take you to 16. You He
just literally just identified in
Hebrews because of Jesus resurrection,
right?
>> I blew on it for you, man. You
>> Jesus resurrection. He just said that,
right? He don't want no JW soup, y'all.
>> So, now John 16. Let's see what Let's
see what's uh what Jesus said here.
Jesus' own words. John 16. What's
interesting, right? Right. Here we go.
I'm I'm going just go to uh 20. Most
truly I say to you, you will weep and
well. It says, "But the world will
rejoice. You
>> will." Sorry. Sorry, Mikey. I'm I'mma
let you to be fair. I'm going to let you
make this last point, but please make it
in in under a minute cuz I I have to go
to another live stream.
>> Oh, okay. I got you. You took five
minutes and you gave me one minute. What
are you talking about? I I spoke with
you.
>> I don't need a minute. I don't need a
minute. That's all. I don't need a
minute.
>> Um I'm just going to get straight to the
point then because we know that um
Jehovah paved the way by means of his
son. This is how now we have the the uh
forgiveness of sin while Jesus died. So
let's see how we get to that point and
how Jesus got that privilege. It says
this is Jesus. So, so you also now, so
now it says you have grieved. Says, but
I will see you again and your hearts
will rejoice and no one will take away
your joy. In that day, you notice it
says in that day, that day you will ask
me no questions at all. Most truly I say
to you, if you ask the father for
anything, he will give it to you in my
name.
>> In whose name? Here's the point. Until
now, wait a minute.
>> Wait. So, the father is the father's
working under Jesus's authority.
>> I got the stage, home, boy. No, no, no.
I got the stage now. I got a minute. You
got to leave me alone.
>> Until now,
>> we just read all the scriptures in the
Hebrew scriptures. ALL JEHOVAH'S NAME.
BUT JESUS SAID, "UNTIL NOW, YOU HAVE NOT
ASKED for anything, a single thing IN MY
NAME." HOW IS JESUS JEHOVAH? AND HE THEY
CAN'T DO nothing in his name yet. Man,
I'm out of here, MAN. YOU SMOKE. I'M
GONE.
>> It just
ain't no way.
Ain't no way. So, wait, hold on a
second.
So ladies and gentlemen, we didn't get
an answer on the angel of the Lord being
identified as Jehovah. We didn't get an
answer on how is it that it's by the
name of Jesus Christ that all are you
call on the name of Jesus and you're
saved. When Joel 2:32 says you call on
the name of Jehovah and all should be
saved. in all the verses that we read,
Psalm 25, Psalm 54, uh Psalm 79 where it
says that in Isaiah 45 where it says
that it's only by Jehovah and for his
name's sake that salvation reaches the
ends of the earth. But then we see that
it's by Jesus's name, the name of the
Christ, that forgiveness of sins is
offered and atonement is is is handed
out. No response to that, but we go to a
verse and guys, let me show you guys how
he destroyed himself and then we're
going to wrap it up. He destroyed
himself by going here. How? Talking to
his disciples specifically. He's talking
to his disciples and said, "You haven't
asked me anything in my name yet as of
yet." We're going to show you how he
just destroyed himself. And this is why
he had to run off. Watch out. Watch.
Watch how Jehovah's Witnesses they they
cannot stand the Bible. They hate the
Bible. HE SAID, "MAN, I'M GONE.
NINJA, I'm out of here." Look, watch
this guys. This is John 14. Talk talking
about name. Listen to this. Truly I say
to you, whoever believes in me will also
do the works that I do. And greater
works than these will he do because I am
going to the father. Watch this.
Whatever you ask in my name, this I will
do. What?
Wait a second. What? What do you mean?
Whatever you ask in my name. So he's
talking about the future, right? So up
until now they have not done this.
But in the future Jesus says after he
goes to the father he says whatever you
ask in my name. Who's going to do it?
Who's going to answer the prayer?
Jesus is going to answer the prayer.
Jesus is going to do it. You talking
about what? Man, you smoked. But
we ain't done. that the father may be
glorified in the son. If you ask me
anything in my name, I will do it." So
Jesus just said that we can go ahead and
pray to him. Jesus just said that he's
going to be the one answering our
prayers, whatever request. Now watch
this because I'm I'm I'm a little I'm a
little lost here because with my logic
my logic tingling. For Jesus to be able
to do whatever we ask, that means he has
to be all powerful. For Jesus to be able
to know whatever it is that we are
asking, he has to be all knowing. For
Jesus to be able to hear believers
everywhere all over the world at
whatever time, he has to be all hearing.
For Jesus to be able to answer every
prayer, every request wherever it is, no
matter what it is, no matter the space,
he has to be omnipresent.
Hm. Omniscience,
all knowing, all powerful,
omnipresent, not limited to space, all
hearing.
Huh? What What do you call What do you
call that has those qualities? Oh, I
know you call him God. Jehovah Almighty,
the one true God. That's what you call
him.
But wait, there's more. Cuz he went to
he went to John 16, guys. Let's make
sure we deal with what he's talking
about. So, not only, ladies and
gentlemen, not only can you request to
Jesus in his name on his authority and
he's going to do it, watch the watch
what he says. Cuz he don't even know
what he did in John 16. Watch what he
says.
Watch what he says. Hold on a second.
Never go full JW, man.
Never go full JW. Watch this. Verse 26,
guys. This is a It's a cut. It's a cut.
Watch this.
Watch what Jesus says.
In that day you will ask in my name.
First of all to my unitarian and
non-rinitarians, why in God's hell
are we asking a creature?
Or are we asking in the name of an agent
instead of Jehovah himself?
Why are we asking in the name of a
created being instead of in the name and
the authority of Jehovah himself? WHEN
JEHOVAH MAKES IT CLEAR ALL THROUGH the
scripture that it's in his name that
salvation is ant prayers are answered
deliverance is had salvation is offered.
Why the in go in in Jehovah's hail
are we asking in a creature's name.
Let's keep going though.
He says in that day you will ask in my
name and I do not say that you that I
and I do not say to you that I will ask
the father on your behalf. For the
Father himself loves you because you
have loved me and and have believed that
I came from God. I came from the Father
and have come into the world and now I
am leaving the world and going to the
Father. So hold on a second.
So we're asking the Father in Christ's
name, in the name of a creature. We're
asking the Father something on behalf of
a creature.
Whoa.
So what Jesus is saying is is that the
father is going to be answering our
prayers in his name. The father is going
to be doing things in the name of Jesus.
Whoa.
So Jehovah acts on the authority of
someone else.
Jehovah the father
acts on the authority of someone else.
Jesus better be Jehovah then.
Jesus just better be another person of
Jehovah
with the father or else this right here
is utter blasphemy.
Imagine a creature saying that the
father is going to work in my name.
Imagine a creature saying that Jehovah
God the the true and almighty God is
going to answer your prayers in my name.
Imagine that. Either Jesus is Jehovah
and the father is one in essence with
the son which is why he can do things in
the son's name or this is utter
blasphemy.